hey what's up it's Gina Rodriguez and
this is the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
yeah I gotta go somewhere with all this
nosy news how to get Gina Rodriguez hair
how do you get Gina Rodriguez hair
I mean depending on how much you pay me
I could send you a few locks what do you
want what are we talking here check eBay
there might be some out there Gina
Rodriguez production company is called a
canonical productions check it out we
got a few shows coming what's up Gina
Rodriguez vegan hail no but that's no
offense to anybody that is a vegan or
just chooses to be a vegan
by all means live your life Gina
Rodriguez Scooby Doo
that's right I'm playing Velma y'all did
you know she was Puerto Rican neither
today
Rodriguez Gina Rodriguez his new Netflix
juice Gina Rodriguez new Netflix I'm all
up and down Netflix yeah
Kobe Carmen Sandiego could be someone
great
it could be jane old things at jane
where you about Netflix Oh more what is
Gina Rodriguez do Oh took two off what
does Gina Rodriguez doing right now
where did Gina Rodriguez grow up
wouldn't you like to know well I guess
that's why you looked it up Chicago I
grew up in Chicago where does Gina
Rodriguez currently live oh oh
I'm everywhere baby careful is Gina
Rodriguez in Brooklyn nine-nine I was
for an episode
what is Gina Rodriguez his phone number
y'all gotta go somewhere with all this
nosy news I ain't telling you my number
depends who is you can Gina Rodriguez
sing hell no no I cannot sing I'm only
saying that so aggressively because
sometimes I sing on Jane when I have a
vocal coach telling me exactly how to
say it
otherwise I'm awful how did Gina
Rodriguez meet Joe lo Cicero oh that's
sweet um I'm Jane he came and he was on
Jane he played Don Quixote and then he
played another stripper and
and he played blue key and he's playing
two more characters and Jane this season
did Gina Rodriguez one did Gina
Rodriguez won an Oscar no not yet
maybe you're projecting the future who
are you the person that wrote this one
day right you would check the Gina
Rodriguez can read Gina Rodriguez can
rap we had to talk about these sentences
y'all we got to talk about what she
writing in this Google can I write yes I
can read when is Gina Rodriguez birthday
July 30th 1984 is my birthday and on
Wikipedia I think it says my name is
Virginia Ernestine it's not that is not
my name my birthday is correct I believe
on Wikipedia my full name is Gina Alexis
Rodriguez that's my real name
Virginia Ernestine what is Gina
Rodriguez is favorite color
what does Gina Rodriguez his favorite
color blue what is Gina Rodriguez is
nationality I'm Puerto Rican what
languages does Gina Rodriguez speak what
languages do I speak English well ish
and I speak Spanish I know one line in
Italian there's no baby anything what
college did Gina Rodriguez go to more
like where did I go broke um it would be
at NYU New York University Tisch School
of the Arts just paid it off last summer
does Gina Rodriguez have siblings do
have siblings I have two sisters and her
older brother those Gina Rodriguez have
a book I have many books in my library
did I write one not yet but when I do
you'll be the first to know oh there's
more
who does Gina Rodriguez voice in Carmen
I've voiced Carmen Sandiego who does
general drinks voice in Carmen Sandiego
I've raised Karma's and evil who is Gina
Rodriguez and big mouth I play Gina who
is Gina Rodriguez as parents
Magali and Gino Rodriguez I am a female
jr. that's not a question you looked up
on Google is Gina Rodriguez related to
Michelle
Rodriguez no I wish I was is Gina
Rodriguez related to Robert Rodriguez no
no there just happened to be multiple
Rodriguez's in this world thank you so
much I learned a lot about what y'all
creepin on on the Internet
it was cute